all right welcome back so we have
introduced the sensitivity and
complementary sensitivity functions
which essentially tell us how our
closed-loop system performs given
reference disturbance and noise inputs
so in particular how do we keep epsilon
small by designing the sensitivity and
complementary sensitivity functions we
also know that s plus T has to equal 1
the identity matrix at every frequency
Omega and so that gives us some
trade-off where if s is low than T has
to be close to 1 if T is low than s has
to be close to 1 and there's this
crossover point where they start to
trade off so I can't have arbitrarily
high bandwidth reference tracking and
disturbance rejection and also have you
know arbitrarily low frequency noise
rejection so there's some cutoff where
above the bandwidth I'm trying to
attenuate noise below that point I'm
trying to have good reference tracking
and disturbance rejection and so the
last part of this is thinking about how
to relate these to the loop transfer
function l because that's something that
has a direct K in it side this is pretty
easy for me to change by changing K so I
know what I want L to look like I can
design a K to give me a good L okay so
it's kind of the last piece of this pie
here is thinking about if I want my
sensitivity function and my
complementary sensitivity functions to
look like these then what should my my
loop transfer function look like
ok so I'm going to draw that maybe over
here and I'm just going to kind of clone
these two plots so I can drive reason on
top of each other
ok and then this one is like that and so
if I want F to be really really small
then the only way I can do that is to
make L really really big ok so for low
frequencies what I want is I want my L
to be really really big I'm going to
erase this we know that s plus T equals
I so for low frequencies what I want is
L to be really really big that will give
me because s is kind of like 1 over 1
plus L ok and so if L is really big s
will be really small for high
frequencies I want t to be really really
small and so at high frequencies what I
want is L to be really really small ok
so really really small plus identity is
just identity and identity plot times
really really small is really really
small so what I want now is for T form
I'm sorry for L my loop transfer
function to be small at high frequencies
and so what you see is that I
essentially get this shape where L looks
like an integrator 1 over s it just
looks like an integrator in the
frequency domain remember this is my
bode plot as a function of Omega and if
L is big at low frequencies I get good
sensitivity if L is small at high
frequencies I get good complementary
sensitivity so Big L at low frequencies
means I have good reference tracking and
disturbance rejection small L at high
frequencies means I have good noise
attenuation and so in general what I
want to do is I actually want to cook up
a controller K so that this loop
transfer function looks like an
integrator 1 over s ok and if I want to
move this thing to the right or to the
left all I have to do is multiply it by
something like W bandwidth over s so if
I want a bigger bandwidth I just
multiply this 1 over s integrator by a
big number so if I multiply this by 10 I
can move it to the right and I can get
higher frequency reference tracking and
disturbance rejection if I think I have
really crummy noisy sensors that have
kind of even low frequency components I
can make W be small and I can move this
to the left and settle for lower
bandwidth performance ok so this is kind
of what we mean when we say high
bandwidth performance
is how far to the right or to the left
this is so kind of where does this
integrator cross the 0 DB line okay so
remember this is all in the complex
sorry this is the frequency response
abuser log of absolute value of L log of
absolute value s log of absolute value T
and so these are all approximately equal
to 1 which is what we want at 0 DB zero
decibels and log is equal to 0 so we
sometimes define this crossover
frequency or our bandwidth as where this
loop transfer function what frequency it
is when it hits the 0 DB line okay
because that's when we have a trade-off
between sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity taking place okay so this
should give us some pretty intuitive gut
feel for what we want our controller to
do given some plant we want our system
to look like this integrator this nice
clean integrator it has high gain at low
frequency and low gain at high frequency
because it has good sensitivity and
complementary sensitivity properties
which in turn give rise to good
reference tracking disturbance rejection
and noise attenuation okay so some of
the next things we're going to do we're
going to figure out well what is the
highest bandwidth performance I can get
how high can I make s you know can I
make s really really big and have really
big gain disturbance rejection and what
are the robustness limitations so what
we're going to find is that the function
s directly tells me if my close whoop
system is going to be robust or fragile
ok so properties of this s function in
particular if my sensitivity has kind of
a big bumped peak like that this is bad
and the bigger this peak the worse the
sense the worse the sensitivity and the
less robust my system is so what I'm
going to try to do is design my
controller Kay to have good loop
transfer function properties and also to
decrease
the bump the highest peak in my
sensitivity function and there are some
beautiful theorems they give you
fundamental limits on how low you can
make that and how robust you can make
your system so if I have time delays or
model uncertainty I can get into I can
tell you kind of fundamental limitations
on how robust I can be and given at what
bandwidth ok and this is getting towards
that idea that LQG regulators never have
guaranteed stability margins or at least
you can always build one that's
arbitrarily non robust we're going to
look at that in terms of the sensitivity
function ok so that's coming up thank
you